I need three results that are quotable
results that you should like no just
like that okay the first one was simply
our definition for the exponential
function if this is on the-- like the
particularly the base of a what happens
when you differentiate in DX just get
back into the air now from that we took
that as our basis to say well you know
what is the special base what's you know
what that is what's you sent in stone
you can work out the roof for an
exponential function with any match
right so we said if it's a to the X
where a is some real number then the
derivative is very similar what's the
difference it's it's a DX times Lord egg
now by the way it's worth mentioning
I mean log is a number right so it's
customary to write numbers first and
then like variable stuff later
but you can probably see why I tried it
I don't usually write the log game first
because they used to have two A's in a
Roman you like which wait is the log the
whole thing is each step it's just their
Baba that's nice if it rolls off the
tongue to a be the X log and from there
we very quickly saw that you can also
differentiate log functions on their own
particularly with their base eight will
talk about what happens women not asleep
in the second
what was the result that we determined
its what an X curiously result yes
yeah sure
the question like is do I need to
justify this and the answer is not
anymore not anymore that you would need
to justify this
you might recall just like all the other
results we got this request principles
right and it took us quite a few steps
to get from here to here but all of
these are quite a window you can just go
for it all right if I'm going to put to
you a quick challenge and I'm not going
to do it on the board right away if this
is with basing this is basing a natural
progression in well this is with Masie
this is with any base this is with Macy
well what would you think include about
this I would just let you have a think
about it first okay I mean the
comparison first of all this transition
here to this transition here it's not as
complicated as it looks so you're a
crack okay I'll let you try I'll put a
question mark there for you don't have
any but how you moment work that out
involves some of the similar kind of
algebraic gymnastics that we did in the
first sentence now I will add on to that
some extra bits that we concluded which
is that if you've got an exponential
function
bassy but you don't just have X up the
time you actually was functional Yeah
right
in other words if you have a chain rule
situation right we saw we know that the
chain rule looks like the polynomials
we've done that to death but now we've
got a fresh spinach so so what it look
like was resolving that pigmentosa
yeah very good F - and then what you'd
appreciate eater whatever you just end
up with that same thing back so that's
why it can be inside you to the outside
either in a function output what we did
notice that much because we kind of ran
out of time is what happens for
correspondingly a lot of functions you
have more of another function
you want to differentiate that okay this
is a beautiful little time again we want
to think just like always it were to
change oh right you should differentiate
inside then the outside right inside
then outside so the inside is just -
right that's you don't need to do any I
mean I don't actually know in this case
what the function is so I'll just call
it that now we're up to my way to
differentiate the outside part that's a
log function when you differentiate a
log function you get what a normal
whatever is in there right one over in
this case X so over here I'm gonna get 1
over this thing here right so I could
write I'm third by this I could write
this right that's that's the derivative
of the outside function you can see
whatever X whatever FX but being that
I'm now finished like I might as well
right I might as well just chuck this on
the bottom and make this a single
expression don't worry about the
derivative of electric is f dash on
efforts a nice it's really simple and we
do so by the way just because now you
know it's not about differentiation
we're not gonna do it right away but
when we get to integration you can see
got everything you've used now seen on
the board gives you something that you
can look for that will tell you to
integrate right so for example if I saw
something like 2x over x squared plus 1
and I was trying to integrate that we're
not quite used to seeing what using this
as a lens to see how integrators yet but
do you see but the
radar is the derivative of the
denominator do you recognize that in
other words this is in the form F - or F
F - Aria which means that's where it
came from right so my heart of this
would be log of x squared plus one
mycosis okay we'll talk about you guys
later ok well that's a bit too you I'm
looking for that there's no reason why
that there at the moment but you can see
this will start to become something you
recognize now I can integrate that
there's a whole bunch more things that I
do so this is what we're this is now our
basis like weekend of robot event
planner everything that's on the board
right now you can coordinate like we've
we've established a recruitment and now
you can simply use them okay now I'm
going to have a look at a question which
I feel like I did not I did not assign
it as question 17
now this is a modest little question
okay
what's great about it is if you have a
look at on the face of it you're like
what do i do read this okay cuz just on
the face of it remember look convene
there for everything right if you were
to pick which which of the rules that I
know which one does this apply to you
right or which rule applies to it I
guess and it's not entirely clear it's
not entirely clear I mean you could sort
of say maybe it's this one maybe it's
that one okay but of course you run into
a problem which is that n is supposed to
be constant like it's X square or X
power Harper doesn't matter but it's
fine and it's another constant here okay
so then you sort of go back to the
thirty boy maybe it's this one right X
is in the power but you end up with the
same problem that he our a is a constant
right and it's kind of important that
it's a cause that's how it all works out
so this is kind of neither of these
straight away which is why I like what I
love that this question is it defies our
desire to just fit questions into rules
right it's not one but that is enough
actually the very surface that were
looking about the point of this question
is not to look at it say which one
should I apply my question to you I'm
gonna give you a few minutes to play
with it is what can I do with this how
can I work with this problem in such a
way that I can reframe it
so this tools that I'm aware of and it
might be some company
can be employed on this there are two
main ways to solve this option employed
but before I do what you have in the
packet what could you possibly do with
these
I guess my clue is you've ever wanted
read some of those trig identities and
you have to solve something that looks
sort of nice and neat on both sides you
like what we're doing isn't nothing
obvious to simplify
there is nothing obvious to simplify
here it's kind of as simple as it gets
so if you wanna make any progress on it
you can after they get a bit messy on
you have to make it a bit worse before
it gets better
that's my clue agent